what was your favorite toy as a kid oh  toys  well um there was i remember there was a  knockoff  of the g.i joe uh doll called  action jackson and i remember being able  i collected a couple of those  um and and and all the you know the the  cars  and all the things that came with the  action jackson toys but they were  cheaper than the gi joes so  you know those ended up you know in my  closet no we were  we were the same kind of kid we did not  have money either and it was like oh the  fancy families could have dr pepper in  their house and we had doctor thunder  okay we couldn't we had all the knockout  things too but you appreciated them and  you played with them  [Music]  you